talk of today
will be uh
quantum machine learning with subspace
states and
honors from uh
qc where we'll be giving a talk
thank you so
so i'll be telling you about some recent
results on quantum machine learning
for subspaces rather than vectors
and this is based on uh joint work with
your dynamic scaling meters and is
available on the archive
so
so although this has been discussed in
detail in the morning
i'll start by a quick overview of
the desired quantum speed-ups as
particularly applicable to quantum
machine learning and then tell you about
the new results and the techniques that
we use to obtain them
so
so in the context of quantum machine
learning i would like to formulate again
three desired criteria
and the intersection of all three has
been very hard to meet
so the first
of these criteria is the quantum
algorithm should be
directly comparable to the classical
algorithm and should be performing the
same
task for example it's not enough to
sample from the solutions to a linear
system and claim that it's same as
solving a classical linear system
second
the quantum algorithm should achieve a
genuine exponential speed up over the
best known classical algorithm
like a high degree polynomial speed up
doesn't
suffice the algorithm should be
resistant to so-called de-quantizations
and further the problem should be useful
in practice and widely applicable for
example it's not enough to you know take
schwab's algorithm for factoring and
reduce it to some kind of
machine learning problem for example svm
so
so so we would like to have
a quantum machine learning that learning
algorithm that satisfies all these three
criteria for speed ups
and again uh
one may find that you can meet two of
the criteria but we think all three has
proven to be um very hard to meet and
and they're no known examples so far
so so let's recall again the promising
aspects of quantum machine learning like
why do we expect that or hope that these
criteria should be met
so
[Music]
so so the first thing is about the
exponential compression of
representations
so for example if you're thinking of the
problem of representing a classical
vector
so in a classical computer you would
store it as an array and you need space
to be order n if you if you wanted to
store a n-dimensional vector so for
example in if n was 16 then you would
have an array with 16 cells and each
element of the array would represent
some coordinate of the vector
now if one uses qubit encodings it it
gives you access to the amplitude
encodings of these vectors
and and clearly one can see that an
amplitude
encoding as on the second line is an
exponential compression compared to the
classical encoding
so such an exponential compression
raises the possibility of an exponential
speedup for qmin
but it should be very clear even looking
at this representation that there are
obvious bottlenecks to realizing this
program right so
so state preparation in the generate
case would require uh multiplier
circuits of depth there's certainly
three parameters um
or the n3 parameters in this quantum
state so so you would need a circuit
with at least 10 gates to prepare a
generic substrate
and secondly um
when you measure the state all this
information is not accessible you can
only perform l2 sampling from the output
and
and with respect to this like
over over the last 10 years a number of
qml algorithms have been uh developed
and if i were to classify them into
families i would name
for the near term the inner product
estimations and turning methods
and then the
more um
computationally involved algorithms of
hamiltonian simulation
and quantum singular value
transformation which which can solve
linear systems and and do more expensive
computations using amplitude encodings
so
so again it's quite easy to claim
exponential speedups for qml but one has
to read the fine print in particular all
these issues need to be addressed
first the input issue of how do you
prepare the initial state for the linear
algebra
procedure for example
the output issue of
of the fact that the quantum algorithm
is sampling from the output while the
classical algorithm is reconstructing
the entire vector
the third issue is about the running
time parameters which should be
interpretable and comparable to
classical running point time parameters
for example condition number may be
rather difficult to bound and this makes
it hard to compare the classical uh and
the quantum algorithms and thus to
establish speed dips
and fourthly
particularly in machine learning the
matrices that arise often dense and
they might have good low rank
approximations or some other structure
but there's no reason to assume that
they will be sparse
so all these caveats were
were known and were pointed out by scott
in in 2014 and
and these caveats make it difficult to
establish end to end uh
speed up for cumulative algorithms
so on the next slide i'm going to
summarize in the intervening years what
has been the progress towards uh
towards addressing these caveats and
what do we know at the present time
so for the input issues like in in
quantum machine learning we would like
to work with generic data sets
so some solutions
were proposed based on the quantum
random access memory and data structures
based on them
but as the qram remains an unrealized
proposal so these uh can be replaced
with parametric circuits in the near
term
and in this direction one can have
logarithmic depth circuits but for the
unity and amplitude encodings of the
vectors
for the output issues um in in machine
learning there might be sampling tasks
which are quite useful
for example uh we had previously this
work on recommendation systems which
worked purely by sampling
and today i'll be speaking about the
problem of determinant sampling which
which is widely applicable in machine
learning and for which we'll see a
polynomial speed up
uh with quantum algorithms and there's
also the related uh literature about
boson sampling and fermion sampling from
the quantum
site
so as for running time parameters one
may argue that if you're looking at low
rank quantum lean algebra then then
these running time parameters are the
numerical rank and therefore a bit more
interpretable and in any case over the
years our understanding for the
parameters that enter into one-to-many
algebra procedures has improved a lot
and we know exactly what these
parameters are
as for dealing with dense matrices um so
according to to the state-of-the-art
current results we can operate with
dense matrices as long as we can embed
them into unitaries that are efficiently
embeddable so example uh so so if you
have an efficient implementation of a
unitary so we can operate on submatrix
of this unit trees in the block encoding
framework
so for today i'll be speaking about a
new approach to quantum machine learning
with that works on subspaces rather than
vectors
and and we'll propose some
candidate exponential
speedups so we'll see we'll come to that
in a bit
so let me uh quickly recall the previous
candidates for the exponential speedups
and why they did not work out well and
why we really do need new methods
so one of the
better candidates for the exponential
speedups which addressed many of these
caveats was our previous work and
recommendation systems
which which tried to
um
construct a quantum algorithm that that
works with sampling so so so the quantum
algorithm was designed to sample from
the high value entries of a preference
matrix without explicitly reconstructing
the matrix
so thereby this algorithm was avoiding
the demand the dependence on the
dimension and had the dependence on the
rank and was considered to be an
exponential speeder
of course under the assumption that
there is good low rank approximation for
the completed matrix which is also made
for all classical algorithms of this
type
so the quantum algorithm had running
time
order k times polylog mn so it avoided a
dependency dimension and had a
dependence of the rank instead
and this was dequantized by tang in 2019
who showed that there's a classical
algorithm with
running time poly k and poly login
and since tanks work there has also been
the quantization of many other qml
algorithms including the principal
components analysis the support vector
machines k-means semi-different
programming and so on so nice uh review
paper by tango authors can be uh well
you know
if you look for it
so
so posting quantization what's the
status of qml so so if we um
so there are three things that one needs
to compare so the first is the quantum
algorithm itself the second is the best
known classical algorithm for these
tasks and and the best quantum inspired
algorithm for these tasks
so these are on the uh very left column
of the table
the running time for the quantum
algorithm scales as k for the
best phone classical algorithms it
scales as a dimension and and the rank
squared and the quantum inspired
algorithm this the state of the art ones
have uh something like a k to the eighth
dependence on on on the rank
so one could argue that uh a speed up a
significant speed up with quantum
algorithms with glutamine algebra could
be possible in some parameter regions
for example if you had a matrix with
about 10 to the eighth users and
products then you can see the numbers on
the right which show that the quantum
algorithm indeed uh seems to be doing
much better in the numbers
but such parameters are certainly very
far away from practice like in the
current regime we do not hope to achieve
them anytime soon
so
so this uh
so this
makes it necessary to develop new
techniques since both the sparse hdl
kind of approach and the low rank
approach to quantum machine learning
have serious limitations
it is uh it is a consensus that new
techniques are needed to
work for the victim but i'm i'm
knowing that you know this k to the
eight is certainly not a uh a lower
bound right you know what would do
wouldn't we expect that it could be
improved uh
so maybe but i would say that uh uh
um
for now
yeah sure for now for now
okay but now the other question was you
know so so tang's de-quantization you
know it does not seem to have been you
know adopted by anyone in practice right
it's uh you know the you know and i i
thought it was because maybe you were
touching on this but like it sounded
like because the recommendation systems
community kind of already moved on to
other approaches right but you know does
that suggest that even if we had a
quantum speed up here that like it
wouldn't really be that useful in
practice because if it was then why
aren't they using that times thing now
what my god really has to order k
dependence somehow right so if you
believe in the k versus the dimensional
thing
so anyway it's a question for when the
quality computers are able to get to
everything right it's certainly not
questions
uh yeah but yeah but uh i'm trying to
think ahead to that time yes
and and so you know like what you know
even if we had the polynomial speed up
for for this recommendation systems
what would that would that even be be
useful
so i would say that it's not just
recommendation systems there's a
spectrum of problems sure all sorts of
so now for new results and a new
approach towards dealing with these
things
so i'm first going to state the new
results so there'll be one polynomial
speed up and two candidate exponential
speed limits
so i have to introduce each of these
problems to you
so the first problem is that of
determinant sampling
so this problem arises in machine
learning whenever there's a feed-off
between relevance and diversity
so for example uh consider a sitting
where you're searching for images
and your query is is jaguar for instance
so if when uh queries only by relevance
then one is likely to get the most uh
frequent items
which might refer to the car
but
if if one is in a setting where you want
to find all the possible things
associated with this query where you
want relevant as well as diverse queries
then you you cannot do uh iad sampling
and in this setting instead
the volume sampling is quite helpful
so for example
the feature vectors for very similar
things like cars in the feature space
would would be uh would have very low um
so when in future space they would be
spanning a very small volume while
those for the diverse and representative
elements would be spanning a large
volume so if there was a way to sample
from the squared volume one one would be
able to summarize the data set and
obtain diverse features from it
so
so mathematically the problem can be
formulated as sampling a set of rows
from a matrix with
n rows and d columns and the probability
should be proportional to the square
volume
and this problem has has found
applications uh at many places in qml so
it's for example applicable to low rank
approximation to least squares
to finding representative summaries of
data set
and even to some um
and it even has some non-obvious
applications to for example defining
this pass to find if your subspace
contains this password and so on
so let's formulate this problem
mathematically so
so the input to the problem is a full
rank matrix
with n rows and d columns
and we needs to sample a subset of the
rows
and the subsets need to have have size d
which is the same as the number of
columns and the probability distribution
for sampling
a subset s is proportional to the
squared
determinant
of a restricted to the
rows in s
so the probability distribution that i'm
writing here is correctly normalized so
this follows from the koshi mini
identity which which shows that if i sum
over all the sub
all the sets s then that a squared
indeed sums up to that a transposing
and and this sampling from this
distribution is an interesting problem
because it it depends only on the
underlying subspace it depends on the
column space of a and not on the matrix
a itself
so one can uh
so algorithmically this means that one
can pre-process the matrix to have
orthonormal columns and this is a
strategy that's used for all the
classical algorithms for this task
and this problem has been studied um a
lot in the classical literature over the
last 20 years
and and the best algorithm was in fact
uh found in 2019 by denizenski clarkson
mahoney and valmik
and
the guarantees for this algorithm them
are that it uses other decubed
arithmetic operations to find uh
subsequent samples from from this
determinant distribution
so the first result uh that i want to
state
big and little d the same thing
yes okay okay so that's taken sorry and
and and uh so i mean like i i i know an
algorithm to do this in time like n
times d squared so is that like the the
easy thing that they were improved so
first because n squared that right was
2006 then it looks like due to default
and execute okay okay right
yeah
so
so the result here is that there's a
quantum determinant starting algorithm
with nd gates
and we'll certainly get d log n
so for example if we look in the regime
where uh d is order n
then then one would see um the gate
complex to the quantum algorithm would
be n squared while that of the classical
would be n cubed so it's a polynomial
speed up in this regime
and further we'll see that there are
some
the matrices with low complexity somehow
so i'll define the complexity measure so
there's a possibility for a cubic
speedup for certain kinds of matrices
but in any case so this is at most upon
normal speedup and it's for the
determinant something problem so that's
the first problem we'll be talking about
so the second problem um
uh it comes about is is regarding
compound matrices so
so for any n times n matrix i can define
uh kth order compound matrix
and and and let's look at this
definition a bit so it's uh so this
matrix will be indexed by the size k
subsets of of the rows and columns of a
and the corresponding entry uh will be
the determinant of the
corresponding minor
so
so think of this as a huge matrix with
with dimension n choose k by n choose k
so then choose k rows and then choose k
columns
the rows and columns indexed by the
subsets of the rows and columns of a and
the entries are given by the minus
so here the theorem is that there's a
quantum algorithm which can perform
single value estimation or
transformation for the compound matrices
of all possible order keys so for all
possible sizes of the subsets k and it
has complexity
polyn so
so the compound matrices are rather
interesting because they have this
kernel property so so every uh spectral
property for example of the matrix um a
often generalizes to the compound matrix
if a is unitary then it's
its compounds will all be unitary and if
it's pst all its compounds will be and
so on
and these compound matrices have in fact
been found to be quite useful in machine
learning uh so vishwanathan and smola
found that um many of the kernel methods
uh um
the quasi-binary contents which are
based on the compound matrixes
generalized many of the currently
methods that are commonly used in ml and
especially to
data that varies with time
so
so let's speak about the nature of the
speed up a bit so
so so classical algorithms would have a
knifely complexity n to the k for
dealing with the compound matrix svd and
bit algorithms have not been found so
far so this is a potentially exponential
speed there
if we look at the quantum inspired
algorithms literature so all these
algorithms have running time polynomial
in the matrix rank
but one can in fact show that if a uh
has a rank r approximation then the rank
of the compound matrix is r to the k so
this will be exponential in
for large enough k and so one would need
new techniques to be quantized the
compound matrix
so of course the open question is to
find uh end-to-end qml application using
these uh compound matrix release as a
primitive
and and what about the svd do we want
like just to calculate a given singular
value or to sample from the singular
values because there there will be
exponentially many of them right it's an
n to the k by n choose k by n
so you can do exactly the same thing
create a superposition
of things and then estimate these like
values like you pay this commission or
put them in attributes like look at that
toolbox for the license
so the third result is about
topological data analysis
and
yeah it seems to be symmetric by the
definition because which is ij
okay let's take this offline if you
think that there's a problem with
generalizing this toolbox
so the third application is to
this problem called topological data
analysis so as this is not a very common
problem and say something about it
so so in the perspective of ml it is
useful because it it captures the
topological the global features of the
data set and it's somehow complementary
to the other machine learning methods
that i commonly use i'll try to do a
very quick formulation of this and show
you that it does arise naturally from
your data sets
so topological data analysis is
formulated on uh simplicity complexes so
these one can think of as a
generalization of grass besides vertices
and edges they have
faces high order faces so they have
faces of water three four and so on
so so given your data embedded in a
metric space
one can uh there's a natural significant
complex associated with it so it's
called the tourist rips complex
so x is the point set uh which is in the
matrix uh space it has endpoints and the
significant complex will include all the
point sets which have diameter at mostly
so there's a scale parameter in the veto
descripts complex and this is a natural
significant complex that you can
associate with your given data set
so now tda is about the spectral
properties of um of
the vitoria scripts complex so one can
define canonically a dirac operator on
this simplicial complex and the
laplacian which is the square of the
dirac operator
and then the dimensions of this uh
graded laplacian operator graded because
it's defined on the order two or the
three and so on faces
the dimensions of the kernels of this
graded laplacian are the betty numbers
and and the claim uh for topological
data analysis is essentially that the
persistent persistent meaning those
which survive over a large number of
distance gains uh betty numbers for
these rips complexes capture shape
features of the data and that's and
somehow useful and complement the other
classical level methods
so so tda
was introduced to quantum algorithms by
this
seminal work of floyd garner and zanardi
in 2016.
so they observed that the dirac operator
is exponentially large and sparse and so
one could use hamiltonian simulation and
use it for quantum tda
but uh so this approach had was using
phase estimation and had large phone
nominal overheads for the reasons the
direct operator simulation was not
efficient and hamiltonian simulation
and uh this has actually been quite an
active topic of research in the over the
last three years and
people have come up with constructions
which reduce the depth to ordain so the
new result here is that there's in fact
a log in-depth embedding for the draft
operator so that gives you a quantum td
algorithm with polylog overheads
so
yeah so i think that's a discussion of
the results i'm now going to move into
the techniques
so it's the same work i'm talking about
the rock operator is a two to the n by
two to the n matrix and that you can do
it with only log of n depth
that's
that could be useful
and we see shortly the how the system is
coming
what is the property why is this
operator called the rack the way that
you're using it it looks more like the
differential of a chain complex
so it's also the boundary operator for
the chain conflicts so
so
and
so it was introduced to quantum
mechanics by directly so and so it's uh
it's also it also goes by the name of
the boundary
okay
okay
well well this is just
this is just semantics
i thought the dirac operating something
else
well they're actually many things yes
the boundary the boundary operator is
what's in your formula lately
yes v is the boundary operator centroid
and it squares people
sure
i think it's called a dragonfred in the
sense that it squares to a hamiltonian
in that sense
that's all it takes
so the central idea which ties together
all these results is this notion of
subspace states
so eventually which ultimately derives
from the fact that the particle or the
unity group acts not only in vectors but
also on the higher dimensional
capacities
so i'm going to give you a definition of
the substrate state so so it's
highlighted on this equation
so so to represent the subspace
one can represent it using a matrix uh x
with n rows and d columns so this is a d
dimensional subspace
and the matrix x is supposed to have
orthonormal columns and uh the column
space of x
is the subspace under concentration
so the quantum representation for this
uh subspace this quantum subspace state
is uh exponentially large superposition
so
so it's a superposition of bit strings
over bit strings with hamming weight d
so that you can think of as subsets of
the rows of of of the matrix x
and the corresponding amplitudes are the
determinants of the
um
s
so in fact this is a one to one encoding
for subspaces it it depends
only on the column space of x and not
representing matrix x
so so and this is because the
determinant remains invariant if you
apply column operation spread so in
particular if you apply
a unit tree v on the right to x
then then you then you do get the same
state
so
so as we see like all these subscribe
states are a part of the hilbert space
of hamming weight b but they are
actually a very small part of it so
so a subspace is only nd parameters the
hilbert space has in
and choose d parameters so the subspace
states form a very special family of the
level d coming with states
and and one particular thing to note is
that all the standard basis states are
the subspace states because they respond
to the matrix which has
some ones in each column
and uh and there's exactly one
determinant that's one and there's
transducers
so this notion of subspace states will
be uh sort of
integral to all the things i'll be
describing here
so if we look uh
just to what's the motivation of
subspace states of the human of what
implications it might have for the
near-term qmm right
so the near-term qml is basically uh
based on using unity encodings of
vectors and trying to do uh different
kinds of inner product estimations
so so one can ask the question what's
the inner product between the subspace
states is and how does it generalize in
a product between vectors
so the inner product between the
substitute states is determinant of x
transpose y if you are calling the
representing matrix x transpose y and
it's the product of the principal angles
between the subspaces
so the inner product between a pair of
vectors is just the cost of the angle
the inner product between subspaces is
the product of the cosines of the
principal angles
and indeed this kind of thing has been
also has also appeared in classical
machine learning so the work of renee
bidal has been on on
trying to classify uh
and cluster using subspace
representations and it may be relevant
to settings where the data has a natural
representation in terms of subspaces for
example
images or video where you're compressing
things and understanding your
species so that's just a slide on why
this might be relevant to qml in the
near term
so
so all the algorithmic the interesting
algorithmic aspects of this work are um
so someone can ask what are the possible
quantum
operations that one can do on these
subspace states and how do you prepare
them after all
so
and how this relates to the results that
i was describing earlier
so in this slide i'm going to list all
the operations you can do and then we'll
look into the algorithms that we have
for doing them
so the first operation is measurement so
if you measure the substitute state in
the standard basis this is equivalent to
solving the determinant sampling problem
so this is the solution from the
definition
so
so if i can give you an efficient
procedure for producing the subspace
states then i also have a solution to
the determinant sampling problem
so the next operation is um
is
is addition or deletion of uh
of vectors to your subspace so so i'll
present some efficient quantum circuits
which add or delete
vector by from from from into a subspace
uh column x
and and the third operation that we can
perform is to rotate the subspace so for
example given the subspace column x how
do i create the subspace
for ux where the uni where the unity u
is being applied from the left
so we saw that when we apply it from the
right the state does not change
and one notion that will emerge uh for
these algorithms is is the given
complexity of the unitary which is
um which is the number of elementary
given rotations that appears in a
decomposition of the unity
so so let's relate it to the three main
results that we said so so measuring the
subspace state uh solves the determinant
sampling problem
and the compound matrices and the td
algorithms will follow from the unit
trees that we construct for addition and
deletions of vectors and rotations
so so we will be constructing certain
unitary operations that act on subspace
states and these will be
the embedded as block encodings in these
bigger unitaries so
so that's somehow the framework of how
this all fits together
so i'm now going to describe to you this
method for addition and deletion of
vectors
and how it relates to
mathematical
technique that that
that is interesting here is um
is the
operator systems which are generated by
mutually anticommuting operators so
these form the classical clifford
algebras
so so interestingly while you can have
any number of commuting operators on on
uh
on a hilbert space even of a small
dimension the
dimension of a hilbert space which which
has uh two n plus one um anti mutually
anti-commuting operators must be
exponential so this is a classical
result of hermann bale that if you have
two n plus one mutually anti-commuting
operators acting on hillary space h then
h must have exponential dimension
and there's a nice quantum proof of this
where a pair of anti-commuting operators
induces a tensor product factorization
of h as h1 times h prime where h1 is a
one qubit space with two of these
anti-commuting operators acting as x and
z
and it's interested in the
verification papers like how to and
resurrect
so so the so the importance of this is
that there's one-to-one mapping between
the space of n qubits and the system of
2n mutually anti-commuting operators
and in fact there's a canonical set of
mutually anticommuting operators which
which can be defined as
i minus one x i and minus i so z on the
first i minus one coordinates x and y x
coordinate and identity and the rest so
i can check that these form again on a
system of mutually anti-commuting
operators
and a uniqueness result tells you that
up to unity conjugations this is the
only kind of system you can have
so i'm i'm going to relate this to
the subspaces shortly so
so the relation between the two was um
is is the gamma map which was introduced
by dirac for his equation in four
dimensions for example
and this can be used to uh lift your
vectors matrices and even higher order
tensors to operators and and to
operators in the clifford algebra
so
so the gamma map for a vector is defined
as follows so it is um
so just as the amplitude encoding of the
vector was x i and uh coupled with the
state so now
we are writing uh
some over these mutually anti-commuting
operators which are canonical in some
sense so gamma x is x i times one of
these mutually anti-commuting operators
and and the mutual anti-commuting nature
of these operators gives you a very
interesting property of the gamma map
so um so if you're talking about the
unit vector which has norm one and you
square this gamma map uh
then it squares through the identity at
t and therefore it's a unity operator so
so this is the natural question of
what's the complexity of implementing
these uh unitary operators
and we'll see that all the power
like the efficient the new efficient
operators in this context are these
implementations of these gamma maps
so the gamma map again you can think of
it as uh embedding a vector as a sum of
mutually anti-commuting operators
and the anticommutativity ensures that
it's a reflection and
so a clifford
loaded circuit uh we define it to be an
implementation of this gamma map unity
and
and one of the main results about the
clifford loaded circuit is that it
performs this addition deletion of
operations on subspace states so when
you apply the clifford loader to column
y and if x is orthogonal to the subspace
y
then you get the subspace state
represented by
appending x to y and similarly if x
already belongs to column y then you get
the state which you obtain by deleting
by from this subspace
and general case of could be a
superposition of these cases so one can
completely analyze the
action of the gamma map on these uh
on these subspace states
so that immediately gives you a
procedure for preparing the substrate
states as well so if you if you want to
um
if you have an orthonormal basis for
your subspace then you just need to
apply the uh the clifford loaders
corresponding to these autonomous
vectors so you apply ca1 ca2 and cad to
0n
and and and by this theorem you would be
getting
the subspace t a because you've added
two
to eight orthonormal vectors in each
step
so so of course the question is how do
you construct the implementations of
these
unity maps and this is closely related
to
the
unity encoding problem in quantum
machine learning so so so to prepare
unity encodings of vectors one one uses
logarithmic uh so we have these unity uh
data loader circuits so which can be
thought of as logarithmic state
preparation circuits
these are structured like like binary
trees and uh
and and have gates which are the beam
splitter gates so i'll be defining these
gates shortly
and and these have
enqueue bits and depth login so so for
example the figure on the left shows you
the the data load or the state
preparation circuit for for
a vector of dimension eight and it has
depth four which is
so
so the two qubit uh gates used in this
context are the obvious gates which act
as identity on zero zero and one one and
rotation on the rest
and and one can define not only these
obvious gates but fermionic analogues of
these obvious gains
so the fbs gate
acts as
either obvious theta theta or rbs minus
theta
and it uh
and this depends on the parity of the
intervening qubits
so so if the parity of the uh qubits
between i and j is even then it acts as
obvious theta otherwise it acts as
obvious minus c
so this is the fermionic analog of the
object which we call the fps gates
so i'm going to describe to you now the
clifford loader construction
so
so the clifford loader circuit or the
implementation of the gamma map is is
obtained by first replacing all the
obvious gates in your
data loader by the corresponding fps
gates so make all the gates for me and
then conjugate so so
so sandwiched between an x on the first
two bit and i on the rest
two from your necklace gives you the
gamma map so this is again one of the
main results on the clipper clothes
so here is a picture of it so you can
see that there's an x in the middle
and the circuits on the left and the
right are obtained from the only data
loader by making all the fps all the
obvious states into fbs gates which
entails certain extra control x and
control z gates so
so this is the construction and
essentially it's log depth and
and all the results derive their power
from this implementation of the gamma
map
so if you want to look into the proof of
this construction then one has to look
on the
action of these gates on subspace states
and and relation with givens rotations
so as i'm coming to the end of the time
i'll skip the proof details and just
give you a quick overview
so so again the main result that the one
worth remembering is uh is disclaimer
that
that quantum that the action of these
fbs gates and the subspace states
implements a quantum givens rotation
so a classical given rotation takes two
rows of your matrix and and takes a
linear combination of them it it adds
cosine of the first probe plus sine of x
second row and so on so classically such
a given operation would uh cost um k
arithmetic operations if you had k rows
in your matrix but quantum value you can
implement it with a single gate on the
subspace state so the fps gate acting on
the subspace state implements a given
given rotation so this factor is already
known for the obvious gate and used
quite frequently in the chemistry
literature but these longer range fps
certainly seem to be new
and then uh uh let's look briefly with
the compound matrix svd so if one so so
so there are two ways to substitute
state preparation so the first is to
decompose your
subspace into a sequence of given
rotations and then replace each one by
the corresponding rbs or fpscape
so this gives you what's called a given
circuit
and if one looks carefully at the given
circuit one finds that
it has the compound matrices embedded in
it
and and not only that so
so the given circuit is unitary so it
has the compound matrices of unity
matrices embedded in that so not only
that if you use a block encoding for a
then the compound matrix uk's block
encoding for ak and on the quantum
team algebra techniques uh carry over to
the setting
so that's uh so that's at the high level
how you get the compound matrix spd
and the dirac operator embedding is is
similar so if we look at the unit frame
implementing the gamma map
so
someone finds that the dirac operator
for the complete simplified complex is
is the gamma map for the uniform vector
which has all the coordinates equal to
one by square okay
and and
and the direct operator for an arbitrary
simplification complex embeds as a sub
matrix of this so so that also gives you
blocking coding for the data operator of
an arbitrary simplicity complex
so by looking at the
matrices which are embedded into these
unit trees that we use for constructing
the subspace states one gets these two
kinds of algorithms
so to summarize we uh we saw three
problems determine sampling compound
matrix spd and tda
and we introduced some new quantum tools
to deal with them so the first were
clear for loaded circuits the second was
given circuits and the third was this
efficient embedding for the dirac
operator
so for determinant sampling the best
classical technique is important
sampling and the quantum three dip is
polynomial n squared versus n cubed in
general case potentially cubic if your
matrix is low given complexity
for the compound matrix svd the best
classical best known classical algorithm
would be some kind of svd and this speed
up so far seems to be
um
a high degree polynomial or an
exponential speed up
and so the direct operator embedding the
speed up is in the depth like the
previous depths were on the end and this
is our login uh
when uh looks for the research questions
that arise
out of uh this
so so the first two obviously to find
end-to-end qml applications using either
the compound matrix spd
or the topological data analysis which
take into account all the factors and
have a potentially exponential speeder
and another research direction is to
look for bosonic compound matrices so
these would be indexed by multisets with
scale permanence instead of the
determinants as increase
then up this methods for
quantum spd with these bosonic matrices
and perhaps they have they have
applications to ml
so
let's conclude with some uh high level
takeaways
so
so so from this work it seems that one
of the promising avenues if you want to
uh
obtain exponentially quantum linear
algebra or ml speedups is to
find matrices that embed in unitaries
which are associated with
non-interacting fermions in this case
but other quantum systems as well could
be candidates for such kind of speeders
the second message is that qml can be
formulated to work not just with vectors
which are fundamental subspaces but for
subspaces of arbitrary dimension
and and the third
being that
if one needs to obtain a quantum speed
up in an applied domain you don't
necessarily have to fit your applied
problem to the quantum technique but
but looking at problems which are
closely related to quantum mechanics may
be another way too
stop there thank you
of the depth proportional to the size in
this case or is it exponentially stolen
so uh sorry could you remember the depth
versus one the circuit depth versus the
circuit size i was wondering you know if
it's
so
my question is if i replace circuit
depth circuit size will it would it be
something like order and log n or
so the previous circuit would probably
have depth
and well i'm not interested in depth at
all
circuit size is
is
um
any other questions
yeah
is there any challenge that is
associated with the rescaling factor for
the blocking codings for those direct
operators
and this is uh so actually so the
this is optimal for the complete uh
situation
so it's needed unity and it's embedding
you know the scaling factor essentially
arises because
so the best you can hope for is a
special norm of your operator that
you're reading and then you have some
anticipation factors so it's occupied
for the complete sentence
and then of course to do pda you to need
a limitation of the
membership
so so um so this this polynomial speed
up or potential polynomial speed up for
determinable sampling uh
you know
it seems like it's analogous to like a
potential polynomial speed up that you
could get for like just sampling the
outputs of clifford circuits
you know that's how it's coming out
right the different circuits naturally
encode the determinant because there's a
lot of cancellation going on there so
right right
um yeah but you know with which you know
it's like like again it's like an n
cubed versus n squared type of thing
right with a cube n squared yeah but um
so for example if your unity had if your
subspace
could be written as a product of n log n
givens rotations right then it would be
a cubic speaker
you know it would be nice to like
understand this analogy in more detail
like can you view the you know fermionic
game splitters that's just some kind of
analog of the quiver group
or are they just two two two
subclasses of quantum circuits that are
just both efficiently classically
simulable for reasons of linear algebra
but for different reasons
so we want to see with the
group yes
yeah and they both seem to admit you
know some potential polynomial quantum
speed up for a sampling test
although although maybe that's the
determinant one is a more practical
interest
anyway just a thought so um all right so
it's uh
the end of the time so let's thank
anapam again
oh yes